[Music]
in november 2021 the supreme court will
hear a case going to the core of how the
united states understands the human
person and justice ramirez versus
collier
the case involves texas denying a death
row convict the right to audible prayer
and touch in prayer in his final moments
but the principles go much deeper for
centuries the western legal tradition
has justified capital punishment
partially because imminent execution can
facilitate repentance thereby
necessitating the presence of ministers
and more broadly many religious
traditions emphasize the vital role of
ministers giving comfort to the dying
history is replete with instances of
deepened faith on death row protecting
the presence of ministers at one's final
moments represents a principle at the
core of the american founding government
power should be shaped around religious
duties ramirez presents the supreme
court with an excellent opportunity to
continue re-anchoring religion clause
jurisprudence in american history and
tradition
here that means ensuring respect for the
dignity and faith of inmates in their
last hour
what do you think
do you think all death row inmates
should have the right to the comfort of
clergy in their final moments
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from aei